you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
have you focused much on the the origin
of signaling i know stuart west who well
i wrote two papers jointly with john
krebs
about
signaling and
the burden of those really was to
refute the then fashionable idea among
ethologists that animal communication
is all about
cooperative transfer of information
so the assumption was made by people
like mile maestro nico tinbergen and and
others of his his colleagues
was that
social life needs kind of oiling
the wheels need oiling by
smooth running communication and the the
signaler
needs to be understood by the receiver
of the signal and and vice versa what
krebs and i substituted for that was a
more manipulative approach we
we thought that
um the selfish gene where looking at
life
was not really compatible with this
highly cooperative vision
of animal signals
and so um when
something like a um a male bird sings
and uh
this causes
the ovaries of the female to grow which
it does that's known physiologically
it's been shown in doves and in canaries
we saw krebs and i saw it as a
manipulation
we made the analogy with
uh the
human experimenter who by injecting
hormones into the female bird could
cause her ovaries to grow
or
a physiologist who sticks electrodes
into the brain
of an animal and makes it behave rather
like a puppeteer pulling strings
we saw the influence of one animal on
another via signals as equivalent to
that
so
the the male bird is trying to influence
the behavior of the female bird or the
or um
of another male perhaps to intimidate
if the male bird was a physiologist
capable of in of injecting hormones or
capable of
sticking
electrodes into the brain of the rival
or the
prospective mate then he would do so but
he can't do that what he can do
is enter the brain of the victim
use the word advisedly
by the portholes which already exist
which are the eyes and ears and nose etc
and that's what he does
and so animal signals crabs an eyesore
as
manipulation
direct influences
on the physiology of the
uh
victim animal and i tie this up with my
idea of the extended phenotype which is
another book that i wrote
where the behavior of the victim can be
thought of as part of the phenotypic
expression
of genes in the manipulator
and the cuckoo is a classic example of
this where
the cuckoo is a parasite but unlike
parasites which live inside the body of
the host
where parasitologists have already
established uh very strong evidence for
physiological direct physiological
evidence of the parasite on the host i
would call
extended phenotypic expression of the
genes of the parasite in the phenotype
of the host in the case of the cuckoo
the parasite is not living inside the
host
the parasite is sitting outside the host
but nevertheless exerting just the same
kind of influence
as a parasite of say a fluke say or a
tapeworm
being inside the host this is direct
manipulation
and krebs and i generalized this
to the notion that all animal signals
are
manipulative in the same kind of way
as the cuckoo manipulating
its host we call i i call that action at
a distance
well the um
would it would always be considered
manipulative if it's helping both
individuals because there are a bunch of
communications that happen that help
both individuals exactly yeah yeah
i could say that the mating call is one
like the female wants to reproduce as
well as yeah it's
both of their best interests right
yeah good good point and in those cases
where it is in both of their best
interests
then the point we made was that rather
than shouting which is what much of
animal signals is about
either literally auditory shouting or
visual shouting bright colors loud
voices and so on you don't need that
if the victim is no longer a victim but
is actually a co-operator it actually
wants to be manipulated so to speak
then the signal ceases to be a shout and
becomes what we called a conspiratorial
whisper
and so you tend to get a decrease
in um
in intensity of the signal in those
cases where the signal
increases in those cases where the
signal gets louder and louder over
evolutionary time or brighter and
brighter over evolutionary time
then our interpretation would be that
that is a is a
manifestation of resistance on the part
of the
signal lee on the part of the victim so
where the victim is resisting being
manipulated you expect the signal to
become louder and louder
and where the victim is
cooperating wants to be manipulated in
other words the world manipulation isn't
really even appropriate where that
happens then the signal drops in volume
and becomes a conspiratorial whisper
so
so quiet that maybe the experiment maybe
the ethologist scarcely even notices it
so that was just a clip from my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below subscribe to this
channel if you enjoyed it
i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh